Speaker 1: All right, we're going to
have a little fun now. My friends,
or we're going to cry because it has gotten so
bad and embarrassing. You might remember what
was previously known as Donald Trump's worst
interview of all time colloquially. And it was
when Jonathan Swan from Axios interviewed Donald
Trump and Trump held up various things and said,
But you can't do that about COVID, and it was a
crazy interview. You might also remember the other
contender for Trump's first interview of all time
when he was interviewed by Chris Wallace and told
Chris Wallace that Chris Wallace wouldn't do that
well on a dementia test, which was completely off
the charts. We have a new interview for you
today that I submit is a top contender for
Trump's most embarrassing, pathetic interview
of all time. This was a much promoted interview
where the interviewer is none other than
MyPillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell,
who we sometimes know of colloquially as Mike
Pillow. The backstory is that Trump and Pillow
became friends sort of at the start of the
pandemic, when Pillow went to the White House
and announced he'd be making masks and he'd be
making different things instead of just pillows.
And this has been a guy who has been one
of the most off the deep end advocates
of the Big Lie making claims about the Supreme
Court is going to reverse the election results,
and Trump obviously won. And I've got routers and
I've got packet captures and I've got a symposium
or a symposium, as he would call it. All these
different things cartoonish up there with Sidney
Powell. So Mike Pillow scores an interview with
Donald Trump. For some reason, we don't know
Trump is wearing a tuxedo, and it's like it might
just be. They agreed to do this when Trump was at
a fundraiser and just walked off stage wearing
a tux and then was interviewed. We don't know.
It just adds to the hilarity. And let's just
jump right in here. Is Donald Trump continuing
to push the Big Lie that he won in 2020? And
he says, Oh, pay, see if you pay attention
carefully. You know how Trump does this thing
where he says, Sir, where, where, when he's lying.
Speaker 4: I don't even know what I'm doing, sir.
Speaker 1: Right. When Trump says, Sir,
they came to me, they said, Sir, it's
a tell that he's making up the story.
There's another example of one of these
towels. See if you can pick it out here.
Speaker 4: We know what happened. Right? You
see it in the report, you see it in everything
and also they're guarding this, so guarding
it, they don't want to give the votes, they
don't want to give the ballots. Mail in ballots
are a disaster. They basically use COVID 19 or
the China virus to rig the election. And it's
a shame. And I hope the Republicans get tough.
Speaker 1: So that was it when Trump says, and
it's a shame, it's another tool that he's saying
something that's not true. The China virus, as he
calls it, was not used to rig the election. And so
when he says it's a shame, it's like when he says
they came to me and they said, Sir, he's lying
Speaker 4: or Mitch McConnell is a disaster
under the guise of disaster, the old crow.
He should have never proved that he should
have never allowed. And it was very sad
when Mike Pence gave those votes over, because
Speaker 1: when you look at Mike Pence didn't give
any votes over, Mike Pence had nothing. Mike Pence
couldn't give the election to Trump. It wasn't up
to Pence, who becomes the next president.
Speaker 4: More votes than you have voters
when you have other things that are so
wrong. And that was then. Now, since then,
many other things have happened which show that
you were right and I was right and people were
right that we're looking at it right? It's a very
Speaker 1: yep. So there is sort of some
self-congratulatory announcement from Donald Trump
that he was right and pillow was right. Then in
the next moment, Donald Trump tells Mike Pillow.
We don't have freedom of the press anymore in this
country, and that will soon lead to communism.
Speaker 4: We don't have freedom of the press
anymore. And you're absolutely right.
That's the first step toward communism.
Speaker 1: So listen, guys, if we didn't
have freedom of the press, Mike Pillow
would not have been allowed to do half the things
he's been allowed to do on various media networks
over the last six to 12 months. That's if there's
any proof that we have freedom of the press.
It's Mike Lindell's media presence over the
last six to 12 months. Trump then talks about
this is his sort of like pity me routine,
where Trump mentions all the money he lost
being president of the United States.
Speaker 4: I expected to lose a lot of money, but
I lost billions. I expected that I was OK. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Now that appears to be a lie
in a couple of different ways. It is true
that during the course of Trump's presidency,
his supposed personal net worth declined. But
why is that? It's because Trump was lying about
his net worth for a very, very long time.
We discovered while Trump was president,
that he was less wealthy than he claimed to be,
and indeed, he also dropped off the Forbes richest
400 list and all of these different stuff. But
remember that Donald Trump made $1.6 billion
during his presidency, an average
of 400 million dollars per year,
and he wants us to believe that he he did a great
public service. He was willing to lose billions in
order to be president of the United States. Trump,
of course. No Trump interview now is complete.
What are the what? What has to be in any Trump
interview? He refers to someone calling him sir.
He tells a lie and says that it's a shame.
He claims that he won the 2020 election, uses
the term China virus and of course, of course,
complains about being banned from social media.
Speaker 4: How are you feeling then? I
mean, was it like a disbelief or was it
across hundreds of millions of people? We had a
tremendous whether it was Twitter or Instagram,
Facebook. I had, you know, just massive numbers
of people. And all of a sudden one day you wake
up and you don't have that voice anymore.
Speaker 1: He woke up and it was gone. It
was just gone. He didn't have it anymore.
Then this is maybe the most delusional part
of the year. Actually, no Mike Pillow at the
end of the interview is even worse than this,
and we'll get to that. But this is maybe
the most delusional part of the interview.
Trump starts talking about specific states again.
He talks about Arizona, and he's like, We need
one big one and two smalls. Or we might be able
to do it with just two bigs. He's talking about
the states he needs to win. It's almost December
of 2021. This election was almost 13 months ago.
He's still talking about the math that'll
get him to two a win in last year's election.
Speaker 4: You said this in twenty twenty first.
Well, I think it's important that they know what
happened in 2020, and once you know what happened,
they have a decision to make. Look, I think enough
people know what happened. You know, we're going
to Arizona. We don't need all this. This is the
big two big ones and three smaller ones, I guess.
Separately, you can have two big ones or you can
have three small ones, something like that. But.
We know what happened. Right? Yeah, you see it in
the report, you see it in everything and also
they're guarding this, so guarding it, they
don't want to give the votes, they don't want to
give the ballots. Mail in ballots are a disaster.
Speaker 1: They basically Trump voted by mail.
Speaker 4: Remember COVID 19 or the China virus to
rig the election? And it's a shame.
Speaker 1: OK, so now we get into what what
we listen to before. So he's still talking
micro like, listen, pillow. If we get Georgia
and Arizona and Pennsylvania, this thing is
over. Sir Joe Biden's been president for almost
a year. What what are you talking about? No, no,
no, no. Two big states and three small ones. And
we're right back in the White House, Mike, I'm
telling you in insane. And then now let me get to
maybe the craziest moment of the interview.
Interviewer Mike Lindell from MyPillow is almost
in tears over how great of a President Trump
was. Now, remember, as idiotic and pathetic as
we believe this to be. There are tons of Trump
supporters that also tear up when they reminisce
about the great presidency of Trump. Look at this
Speaker 4: is the way God intended it,
because everything that you did to show us
what a great leadership should be right and
what it can manifest to to help all people
were alive and to have a great life in this
country, a best country in the world. And I
want to thank those millions do for being
the greatest president we've ever had.
And we appreciate you. Your honor and the good
news. We're going to look back at what they did.
And we're going to say they did a terrible job so
they won't be able to talk right because the job
they've done is record setting bad and we're going
to take back our country. Yes, we are. Thank you,
my pleasure. Thank you very much. Thank you.
Speaker 1: God bless. God bless
the United States. What a bizarre, bizarre
interview. And it's almost you watch it
and you're like, nothing could top
the things Trump is saying while
sitting strangely while wearing the
tuxedo and then pillows almost in tears
over what he believes to have been the greatest
president in the history of the United States.
You Saturday Night Live is out of business,
folks. Saturday Night Live is out of business